he wears a diaper just like you do
[Music]
my name is Adam and this is my little
girl Samantha and this is her favorite
stuffed animal
you give them oh no big hugs give mommy
kisses you're like monkey what does the
monkey say ah that's right and today I'm
gonna do a magic trick and turn it into
a real animal for her I know that's
right that's nano moan oh is Spanish for
monkey and she pronounces it nano all
right are you ready all right going to
close her eyes you won't play peek-a-boo
with nano wow yeah all right one two
three
who's that what is that that's right
that's a monkey what does the monkey say
look at the monkey go you like the
monkey usually do introducing flame
trick oh yeah look at him go say hi
monkey okay there he goes there he goes
[Applause]
do you love nano yeah there is
there's the makey huh you just want at
it real bad don't you
is the monkey eating yeah no say hi nano
up
yeah the monkey went up that's right
careful all right let's say bye bye say
bye bye bye bye here we go
one two and then there's no so this was
awesome for me I could tell that she
really liked the monkey she just kept
trying to get at it and give him big
hugs like she does with her stuffed
animal I don't know if she bought the
fact that the animals switched into the
monkey or not but she had a good time
until they took the monkey away okay
okay
[Music]